but another part of me thinks what if by
some miracle we stay and actually make
it out of here Tom Sizemore has died he
was 61 years old
[Music]
the actor suffered from a brain aneurysm
as a result of a stroke on February 18th
Tom's manager shared in a statement that
he remained in critical condition in a
coma an intensive care and his family
was deciding on end of life matters
after doctors informed them that there
is no further hope well so far so good I
got a bunch of movies coming out yeah
yeah I've been very lucky I'm very happy
just hours before the incident Tom
shared this throwback photo featuring
his co-stars in the 1995 crime drama
Heat
I got plans I'm going away after this I
did heat opposite you know I don't know
if you're not I'm starting opposite
dinero and Pacino and they're real good
too so
the higher caliber actor you can work
with the more exciting it really is you
know it's it's they make you better
Tom's acting career peaked in the 90s
and early 2000s it's been a gradual for
me you know I'm just starting to
play bigger roles and the leading roles
he starred in films including Strange
Days Black Hawk Down and Saving Private
Ryan
like you said captain
we do that
we all earn the right to go home like
Private Ryan for instance was not
necessarily fun it was very satisfying
so you know making movies isn't
glamorous
making movies is hard Tom also had a
small but memorable role in the 2001
film Pearl Harbor
hey come back around we're gonna need
more than a shotgun you got any other
weapons and ammo we can lay out some
cover fire inside that ammo Locker I
really liked all the guys they were all
extremely excited although most of their
big first movie right right so it was
great they're all very Earnest and full
of energy and passion it was it was
great they're good great great group of
guys Tom is survived by his twin Sons
Jagger and Jaden
thank you